do aussi de l'hydroélectricité depuis sa
création en 2015 j'aime hydro a fait un
malheur avec plus de 120 représentations
et près de 70 mille billets vendus
encore au début de l'année on présentait
la pièce à guichet fermé j'en ai entendu
que du bon dans cette pièce c'est un
nouvelle forme de théâtre parce que ça
fait différent les classiques on les
connaît tous en plus de jeunes hydro
d'autres créations connaissent un grand
succès qu'on pense à la pièce la meute
un drame sur la vengeance ou encore à la
pièce les holdings sur la tragédie de
lac mégantic
les chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes en 2004
il ya eu dans les théâtres québécois 280
pièces de création et ce chiffre a
doublé en 2018 pour atteindre 632 pièces
de création même si plusieurs de ses
pièces de création n'ont été joué qu'une
seule fois le nombre de spectateurs a
aussi grimpé
il a dépassé le million en 2018
j'explique ça de différentes façons j'ai
vraiment l'impression qu'en ce moment on
est dans un espèce d'âge d'or du théâtre
québécois et je m'explique le théâtre
québécois est assez jeune ce territoire
je travaille qu'une belle ça il ya
cinquante ans à peine qui les héritiers
de tremblay ont engendré d'autres
héritiers j'ai l'impression qu'on est à
cette troisième génération le qui est
très foisonnante qui écrit sur plein de
sujets qui est très diversifiée loire
le théâtre du nouveau monde présente des
pièces de répertoire
mais il a toujours misé sur la création
c'est vrai qu'on assiste à une vague de
fond qui j'espère ne restera pas une
vague de fond on va devenir son ami
parce que c'est vrai que la création
c'est quand même très important pour
l'identité d'un peuple oui je pense
qu'on peut dire que la création se porte
bien
pas encore très bien mais elle se porte
bien elle est diffusée elle est vue elle
rayonne et elle est appréciée par le
grand public bâlois en blanc immaculé
les salles de jeux
tandis que le théâtre de créations vit
de belles années aussi en partie dû au
théâtre pour enfants le théâtre de
répertoire qui comprend entre autres les
classiques de molière de shakespeare et
les reprises de pièces à succès écrite
au québec est en chute libre
le nombre de spectacles est passé de 103
en 2004 à 68 ans en 2018
s'ils n'y survivrait pas et le nombre de
spectateurs a baissé de moitié passant
de près de 700000 à un peu plus de 300
milles pour la comédienne julie le
breton il s'agit d'un mal pour un bien
dans les termes de répertoire sur tout
le répertoire qu'on connaît qui date de
plusieurs siècles il ya pas beaucoup de
rôles féminins intéressant dans le
théâtre de créations comme beaucoup de
femmes qui écrivent aussi que me qui
donne qui écrivent des beaux rôles pour
les femmes il ya davantage d'équité je
dirais dans les rôles le théâtre de
créations est sur une lancée
une lance et qui pour plusieurs ne
s'arrêtera pas il faut pas rigoler tout
en étant ici louis philippe ouimet radio
canada montréal